like I am so sad and I just don't even
know what to do and like
I don't even I don't even know it's the
circle of life on Sister Wives as Mary
deals with the death of her mother
Bonnie and Christine's daughter mckelty
brings new life into the world
they don't call it the Miracle of Life
for nothing
first it's an emotional time for the
Browns as they're rocked by Mary's mom's
death the TLC star getting the
heartbreaking news on her way to the
hospital it was about an hour after I
was on my way that I got the call
I just got a call from my sister
and we lost my mom
I don't even know how to do this
this is so unexpected and so quick and
for Cody Janelle Robin and Christine
they also mourn the loss and remember
Bonnie's Legacy I'm broken-hearted about
Bonnie's passing she was such a blessing
to our lives every time I was around her
it was a sweet experience
and she always made me feel welcome
after
my mom left our church
people didn't know what to do with her I
didn't know what to do with her she just
always pushed for me to reconcile with
my mom always
and that's just Bonnie to the core
there's looseness that you have when
you're all living together and that
closeness helps no matter the situation
my Kelty is pregnant so
I'm so excited for another grandbaby
coming for all of us
um it's been fun fans got a full glimpse
of Christine becoming a grandma once
again as she and Robin stick by
mckelty's side as she gives birth to her
baby girl Avalon
I just I'm a lot closer to those two and
I'm a lot more bonded to those two than
I am to Janelle or Mary I'm just I'm not
close to them and I wanted to make sure
that my birth was very much about
selfishly I want my birth to be about me
but for mckelty it wasn't an easy feat
she was in labor for over 24 hours and
at one point the baby's heart rate
dropped that cord was wrapped around
Avalon
like three or four times she's been
pushing and the baby keeps on getting
yo-yo back up but that can't happen
anymore we can't get her heartbeat
eventually after a few more pushes
Avalon arrived
so Avalon ASAP padron is now born
oh my gosh she's beautiful
it's really one of the most humbling
things to watch in this life
is
um to watch your kids become parents and
now mckelty and her husband Tony's
family is growing once again a little
over a year after Avalon's birth the
couple announced they're expecting twins
[Music]